[Musique]
les soldats israéliens retranchés
derrière des postes d'observation
renforcés l'arme à la main prête à
servir à tout instant nous sommes
pourtant dans la ville palestinienne de
wara en 6 Jordanie
comme
plusieurs routes et un carrefour
important dans la ville
édifices même des commerces pour sévir
contre nous
une situation qui étrangle la vie
économique de l'artère principale
dénonce le maire
toutes ces mesures répressives et ces
pratiques de terreur contre la
population de wara c'est pour vider la
ville de ses habitants particulièrement
sur la route principale
pour aller d'une colonie à l'autre c'est
comme ça depuis le 26 février dernier
dit le maire
ce soir-là des dizaines de maisons de
commerces et de véhicules appartenant au
Palestiniens ont été incendiés des
civils au hasard agressés
[Musique]
de nous nous avons commencé à crier
alors lancer des pierres ils ont tout de
suite ouvert le feu avec des balles
réelles sans utiliser les balles de
caoutchouc ou les gaz lacrymogènes en
avertissement mon frère que Dieu lui
pardonne a été touché à l'estomac par
une batte expansive qui explose
ils étaient entre 300 et 400 colons
selon l'armée israélienne
en dévangile la mort de Hilel et yagel
Yani les frères
âgés de 22 et 20 ans ont été tués par
balle sur la route principale de wara
plutôt dans la journée
[Musique]
le comité de coordination
israélo-palestinien et nous leur avons
dit que des colons allaient nous
attaquer que nous avions besoin de
protection malheureusement la protection
ce sont les colons qui l'ont reçu pour
les aider à nous attaquer
la famille de Samé a porté plainte pour
son meurtre mais elle ne s'attend pas ce
que justice soit faite
selon la directrice du ONG israélienne
qui documente la violence des colons
ainsi Jordanie dans 93% des cas aucune
accusation ne sera portée et les
accusations retenues des bouches sur des
condamnations dans seulement 3% des cas
si vous regardez le portrait d'ensemble
je dirais que ça vient des politiciens
et de ceux qui décident de gouvernement
aux contrevenants au côlon mais aussi à
la police et à l'armée israël ne veut
pas d'enquête approfondie ne veut pas
prévenir ce genre de France
les attaques des collants sur les
Palestiniens sont idéologiques
croient-elles
sont commises pour prendre les terres
palestiniennes et chasser les
Palestiniens de chez eux en leur faisant
peur quand vous parlez de d'État occupé
l'état occupé c'est pas nous qui les
occupent c'est les Arabes qui les
occupent
vous voyez cette route là c'est rarisson
nous reçoit chez elle une caravane
qu'elle habite avec ses 7 enfants et son
mari dans la colonie de réélim pas très
loin de wara
elle est venue de France il y a une
vingtaine d'années une arrivée qui est
prédit dans la Bible croit-elle
il y a quelques semaines c'est rare et
sa famille défilait avec des milliers de
collants à heviatar il y a deux ans ils
y avaient établi un nouvel avant-poste
on habitait un mois dans des tentes et
puis après un mois on a construit là-bas
des maisons il y a beaucoup de femmes
qui sont arrivées et puis après deux
mois et demi il y avait déjà 50 familles
qui habitaient là-bas
aujourd'hui on n'essaye pas de
reconstruire juste et viatar on essaye
de reconstruire tout le pays c'est la
terre elle nous a attendu de Milan
les ministres du gouvernement de
Benyamine Netanyahou dont le ministre de
l'Intérieur est à marbellir y était
nous n'avons pas peur nous avons
légalisé 9 avant-postes et avec l'aide
de Dieu nous en légaliserons des
dizaines d'autres
avec l'aide de Dieu et à l'abri de la
Cour suprême c'est en pleine crise
politique autour de la réforme
judiciaire qui viendrait ronger les
pouvoirs du plus haut tribunal du pays
qu'il a fait ses déclarations
quand on regarde le gouvernement et
qu'on voit qui en charge c'est une image
qui fait peur il faut être idiot pour ne
pas faire le lien entre deux révolutions
d'abord la révolution judiciaire ou la
réforme comme il l'appelle mais il y a
aussi une révolution de l'indexation que
même ce gouvernement révolution
2022 a été l'année la plus meurtrière
pour les Palestiniens si Jordanie occupé
depuis la fin de la deuxième Intifada en
2005 selon le nu 150 Palestiniens sont
morts lors de Red de l'armée israélienne
et d'affrontement
les attaques terroristes palestiniennes
elles ont fait 30 morts israéliens le
chiffre le plus élevé depuis 2008
pendant qu'on accuse le gouvernement
israélien d'attiser les tensions
l'Autorité palestinienne le gouvernement
semi autonome de la scie Jordanie brille
par son incapacité corrompu et affaibli
elle n'est qu'un sous contractant de
l'occupation pour bien des Palestiniens
la vue sur les collines de la scie
Jordanie a beau être dégagée l'horizon
ici semble inexorablement bouché